comme mentale et vous moi ça m'a un peu
stressé et comme d'habitude avant les
vidéos activités manuelles écoutez je ne
pouvais pas lors de ces vidéos activités
manuelles ne pas essayer le maquillage
il ya des chiens de youtube basé sur
cinq qui font des millions et des
millions de vues c'est tout un art c'est
beau ça se maîtrise ça se dompte c'est
bon j'ai fini mon discours aujourd'hui
on va pas faire du maquillage simple à
faire du maquillage est fixé un truc que
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup au cinéma
olivier notamment je suis un conte un
stade ailleurs dont j'ai oublié le nom
mais ça ça fait ch à l'écran j'ai tenus
par des gars qui font des effets
spéciaux pour les films d'hollywood donc
gros budget qui font des maquillages en
découdre au son des visages entier en
prothèses etc s'est assaini
à l'époque je regardais même une
émission où ces dégâts qui s'affrontent
sur cette émission télé sur une chaîne
de perdus chez puis laquelle on envoie
c'était des mecs qui s'affrontent pour
faire un maquillage f6 dans un thème
précis genre faire une créature
aquatique faire un démon bref c'est un
truc que je trouve assez ouf est
impressionnant mais qui est très très
complexe à faire donc comme d'hab
tu peux t'en sortir et faire un truc un
peu whaou sans être très fort par contre
qu'il ya des gens qui font des trucs de
dingue
et pour arriver à ce label là il faut
avoir pratiqué pendant des milliers
d'heures bref aujourd'hui je vais
essayer sur moi même de faire deux
choses en fx mais avant ça sachez une
chose j'ai du mal avec le fait de mettre
des produits sur mon visage j'ai
vraiment du mal à chaque fois que j'ai
été maquillé avant un clé par exemple
départ récemment avant un court métrage
avant une vidéo à l'époque j'ai pris les
mines graves c'est un moment la face je
me fait maquiller que je déteste
profondément j'ai fait un effort
halloween dernier je me suis maquillée
en vampire et pour ça j'ai mis de la
poudre blanche sur mon visage et du faux
sang au coin des lèvres et j'étais très
fier du résultat
on va commencer tranquille avec tout
simplement une morsure de zombies et
après ça les amis un make up qui est
incroyable et qu'on a tous rêvé d'y
entrer dans notre vie voldemort
voldemort bref c'est parti nous sommes
donc sur la chaîne de juliette à make-up
369 vue sur ce tuto qui est pourtant
excellent veut ça y est j'ai une boule
au ventre on y va salut salut les hauts
lieux
on attaque tout de suite avec la suite
de la série pré halloween avec la mono
mort sur des souris elle m'a mis dans
une ambiance de folie
je suis ipod il nous faut des phares
gr.d quoi ils nous font
des phares à des fins gr1 galette et la
colle un pastiche cdu si lors la colla
postiches
moi j'ai un truc c'est du silence et de
la wax de couleur chair donc celle
voulue et de l'awacs de couleurs face à
jay jay du place tonate cars
suis je présente des produits à la
caméra j'aurais dû préparer un code
promo soir était dingue ce moment j'ai
commencé par c'est un bleu sur une zone
assez restreinte et en forme de cercle
hockey comme enfin bleu pour savoir
comment réaliser des bleus je vous
renvoie à ma précédente vidéo où
j'explique la méthode à suivre
tiens tu tour dans un tuto si jamais
arrivé non mais un bleu mecs pas
compliqué tu prends du bleu du blanc du
jaune tu fais tes veines les i fuck un
moment on va être créatif il va
surpasser aussi alors j'ai juste bien
regarder la couleur calme et avec mon
daltonisme elle commence par mettre du
jaune simple et ensuite elle met du mur
est franchement et ça va je suis
vraiment une merde qui arrive pas à
faire ça c'est suis désolé c'est un peu
amusant c'est la première fois c'est bon
je peux gdra 30 pays ok c'est pas mal là
on y croit un peu aux bleus en bresse
pas mal
ok après le fait d'être vaine et elle
efface les veines [ __ ] on n'y croit
pas on y croit un peu là en vrai c'est
réussir un trou dans le vif du sujet en
prélevant un peu de boxe
j'en serais deux petits boudins ça me
rappelle tuto pâte à modeler place
tonate scars wax ça n'a aucune odeur ça
sans rien c'est presque décevant moi
cette texture tellement stylet c'est
l'heure de sortir le 6 à l'ordre
on va prendre ce pinceau ok maintenant
je vais mettre les boudins tu as ça
c'est que l'entraînement après à
voldemort
j'aime me rappelais voldemort c'est le
vrai challenge avec une spatule ou avec
lui 12 12 ans appuyée par exemple
j'aplatis le côté extérieur de la plaie
pour la faire fondre avec ma peau j'ai
pas de spatule voilà ça te va ou pas
comme information mais je vais le faire
avec le dos du pinceau ça marche pas du
tout ça ça me rend malade je vais
prendre dos d'une cuillère
[Musique]
ok faut vraiment gl tout doucement fait
ok et là j'ai gagné mais se passe un
truc et regardez regardez bien ça va
alors j'avoue il avait la mâchoire
cassée ce qui explique que c'est pas
droit mais à part le fait que soient pas
bien droit franchement des bords j'ai
bien fusionner le souci c'est que j'ai
pas de matière grasse normal matières
grasses permet de re taper sans arracher
moi j'ai pas de matière grasse au vêlage
et particulièrement galéré pour cette
partie là attends je vais quand même
appelé lorraine puisque j'ai pas
d'emprunt j'ai pas de matière grasse
bien sur la messagerie de lorraine bah
je vais mourir
le blème c'est que ça lahouel fait des
traces de dents mais sans matière grasse
roll à sa matière grasse ça ça va être
dur mon dieu regardez ça s'arrache
en fait je vous explique quand j'appuie
sur la pâte à modeler elle se craque en
deux secondes
la matière grasse le but c'est que ça
rend le truc modelable ça mène à bon
c'est pas si mal
bon ça bah en fait bref c'est quoi la
suite j'en peux plus je veux passer à
voldemort qui je fixe du tout avec des
à-coups de nos livres ou du tac la
farine si vraiment vous n'avez rien chez
vous vous doutez bien que je fais une
vidéo sur le truc c'est que j'ai prévu
les choses et que je fixe et c'est avec
un bon produit pas de la farine
ok alors bon on dirait que j'ai delà de
la pâte à pain quoi sur ben vas-y au
caire je suis abattu
en fait là j'ai vraiment réussi là j'ai
pas réussi et le truc de matifier en
fait ça ne colle toujours pas à mon bras
donc c'est ce qui est embêtant attendez
vous étiez en train de vous dire et
voilà ira tout comme d'hab c'est même
plus drôle faut sans toi tu étais truc
rouge la mignon c'est bien bravo
regarde moi ce que je vais m
home alors non il n'ya plus personne tu
l'avais pas vue venir celle-là juliette
je suis en compet avec les guerres dont
je regarde les petites aux gets alain
peut hélas même si ce que j'ai fait
c'est à chier on y croit parce qu'il ya
du sang non mais là ça fait une heure on
s'attend à ce que ce soit faux on est en
train de la faire ensemble
mais imaginez jour d'halloween j'arrive
en balle ou kaka pas de déguisement
chapeau l'artiste
hop je tends la main pour l'insérer
[Musique]
mais sinon c'est pas si mal
bayador rapprochera j'ai raccroché
bon c'était l'entraînement le vrai
challenge c'est ça les gars ça commence
bien
alors elle a vu ses sourcils avec de la
colle à sourcils alors ça je connaissais
pas assez désagréable je vais le mettre
à la fin il fait trop chaud
je suis comme un porc à temps mais elle
elle vient de coller ses sourcils mais
je vais pas essayer une colle big
classique pour coller mes sources il ya
bien une colle spéciale de gens du make
up
bah je vais pas le faire je le fais pas
folle où je vous parle
voldemort est un personnage qui n'a pas
donné toutes les vidéos make-up qu'il ya
sur youtube pour faire voldemort demande
l'utilisation d'une prothèse fait en
amont sur mesure qui vient équilibrer
l'épaisseur entre la et là je n'ai bien
entendu pas le talent pour faire cette
prothèse et sa demande des jours
puisqu'il faut moule et ta gueule et la
faire à partir de ça ce tutoriel est le
seul tutoriel où tu peux devenir
voldemort sans faire cette prothèse de
aux fondamentaux que seulement 1% des
gens sont capables de faire on va donc
faire la méthode bien rustique de
s'aplatir le nez avec riesch coach alors
le blème sais que j'ai un sacré puisses
tu peux pas je peux pas me la tire plus
que ça tu vois comme ça c'est pas mal
déjà donc là elle ajoute du latex pour
créer de la matière à plein d'endroits
et pour ça j'ai pas trop envie
d'utiliser du latex parce que c'est
chimique et ça pue ça pue ok je suis en
colère donc je vais utiliser l'espèce de
pâte à modeler qui est beaucoup moins
nocives
je vais essayer de me faire une sorte de
prod2 prothèses de part et d'autre du
visage
nathan mais c'est excellent et les husky
tennisman
[Musique]
et bien c'est ouf alors à chaque fois
que je parle tout risque de krach et une
bouger mais j'ai réussi à faire ce dont
tu parlais à cacher un peu le le relief
de monde et je suis trop content
ok alors le programme
je suis voldemort si j'avais été malin
j'aurais gardé de la pâte et j'aurais pu
faire un truc comme ça faut essayer de
créer la fusion entre le risque et moi
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que jamais
du parc du sparadrap est logiquement en
aplatissant bien voilà la transition
elle évoquera mais j'ai bien dû
logiquement alors elle elle met du blanc
mois au magasin ils m'ont donné la
couleur de voldemort donc déjà
quoi qu'il arrive je serai plus
voldemort qu elle
[Musique]
ça marche pas du tout c'est quoi je vais
le faire en blanc et après je mettrai la
couleur de voldemort
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est nul la prothèse et tous
et pas dégueu parole j'ai plus de l'efs
duo mais elle non plus sans faire exprès
je me suis fait ce truc de mechria que
la veille du bac et bouge chez content
ça se bosse bio je vais me faire un
court et avec du vert puisque c'est plus
vers la couleur de voldemort par dessus
tu vois une petite surcouche comme ça
c'était mieux en blanc je remets du
blanc donc elle rajoute du nord autour
de ses yeux ça je peux le faire non
[ __ ] juste voldemort avec un mono
sourcil et qu elle a caché ses sourcils
à qu'elle va voir ses sourcils ont
disparu ce que quelqu'un a vu ses
sourcils d'histoire étoiles elles
deviennent coller ses sourcils mais je
vais pas essayer une colle big classique
pour que les mets sourcils
là je vais pas le faire je ne fais pas
trop haut
alors ça c'est une étape qui me plaît
énormément ça le truc a pas raté
[Musique]
explique hermès c'est en sorte qu'il
fait mais impossible elle se creuse les
joues avec de la poudre aux normes j'ai
pas de poudre noire
j'ai que de la poudre d'escampette j'ai
fini genre j'ai fini si un événement de
fans d'harry potter et j'arrive comme ça
est-ce que les gens kif
où est ce qu'ils se foutent de ma gueule
évidemment qu'ils se foutent de ma
gueule et cyrus le vrai test ce maître
lorraine
lawrence lam dire si le résultat est à
la hauteur
[Musique]
honnête ça se détache d'une very bag
voilà oui mais c'est je rigole ça craque
de partout faut pas que je rigole mais
siens face à voldemort dans les films il
ya tellement plus choquant mais là ça a
craqué parce que j'ai rigolé avant
c'était mieux je te jure d'énergie
produit tant d'argent ça m'a coûté cher
je vais appeler jordan jordan jamais va
critiquer ça lui ferait trop mal au
coeur si même jordan n'a pas pu cacher
qu'ils trouvaient ça pas ouf c'est que
vraiment c'est pas ouf au haut des
points noirs
c'est horrible joel chin et honnêtement
un énorme respect à tous ceux qui font
du [ __ ] de mecha préfixe parce que
c'est tellement dur j'ai tout donné
j'y suis allé bonne foi je me suis dis
franchement ça va le faire c'est dur
mais j'ai tout ce qu'il faut j'ai acheté
les bons produits et tout mais ça ne
suffit pas il ya un truc qui ne
s'achètent pas c'est le talent c'est bon
en vrai ça c'était un peu cool mais juge
avait pas de poudre j'avais que des
trucs gras comme ça et je pense que
mètres du fond de teint pour fondre le
truc et le matifier pour le rendre plus
réaliste un beauf qui a heureusement le
fossan à sauver un peu le truc mais ça
reste pas dingue
ah je sais qu'à chaque fois que c'est le
même scénario a de quoi vous détaille
fait exprès à la longue mais non c'est
vraiment dur les activités coupe
j'aimerais tellement réussir et faire un
truc quoi ou la vidéo elle serait dix
fois ci elle pas les vidéos j'aurais
jamais une courage de tenter ce genre de
choses jamais je suis vraiment content
de m'être une discipline le temps d'une
vidéo de passer un mois et vous ça me
fait plaisir en bresse avait bien
commencé quand s'est mis les prothèses
et tout sur le visage qu'on a essayé
d'équilibrer le niveau
nez les pommettes et après je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé quoi mais c'est parti
en vrille
tout est allé si vite je remercie
d'avoir regardé la vidéo en vrai c'est
un peu style et à faire genre ce truc de
faire des plaies tout pour halloween
j'essaierai de faire quelque chose de
deux noms j'essaierai pas je suis en
train de mentir
plus jamais je vous dis à bientôt
portez-vous extrêmement bien fait
attention si vous voulez faire du mc
alger etc
au fait ça avec des propos des gens qui
connaissent parce qu'il ya plein de
produits quand même préféré garde c'est
pas pas faire n'importe quoi portez vous
bien
je suis folle de mort
[Musique]